s'il y a des réparateurs devenus des
changeurs de piles il y a encore forte
heureusement pour les collectionneurs
des horlogers capables de comprendre les
mécanismes les plus complexes de les
ouvrir de les démonter de les réparer et
même de remplacer les pièces
défectueuses en usinant des identiques
s'isoler dans le métal
l'hor
Logerie on travaillait directement sur
l'objet en lui-même et donc on vient
travailler par ajout de matière ou
carrément on vient retravailler une
pièce c'est à dire on travaille beaucoup
avec du laiton de fonte ou des barres
pleines qu'on vient travailler en fait
sur ce genre de tour pour leur donner la
forme qu'on veut
le talon de Marion s'est forgé auprès
d'experts qu'ils l'ont accueilli en
formation maintenant installé dans son
atelier en Touraine elle le sculpte les
battements parfois irréguliers de
rouinge créé entre le 17ème et le 19e de
diagnostic en résolution la réparation
s'apparente de temps à autre un jeu de
piste à plusieurs inconnus
ça peut arriver qu'il y a certaines
réparations qui soient plus difficiles
que d'autres
chaque pendule est différente en fait ce
qui est important c'est de prendre le
cheminement et de faire une sorte
d'enquête c'est-à-dire que l'horlogerie
a des grandes règles de fonctionnement
et mécaniques donc si on a fait
correctement notre révision mais que il
y a des problèmes qui résistent ça peut
arriver il faut tout reprendre depuis le
début et faire par élimination
quelquefois il faut aussi chercher un
endroit où on s'y attend pas Marion
n'ouvre pas les montres bracelets elle
s'est fait une spécialité d'aller
chercher le grain de sable qui empêche
les précieuses ancêtres de tourner rond
de sonner à l'heure juste Louis XVI le
disait l'horlogerie est une chirurgie